you say that a lot of uh the comics like
the guys that you were
sort of coming up with or that were in
the clubs at that point who were the
guys you would
because you said there's like an a-list
bunch of guys when i was coming up
i remember in new york and this is like
in the beginning time i mean
the the guys that were in and out of
this comedy circuit were
i saw chris rock i saw george wallace i
saw
seinfeld i saw ray romano i saw colin
quinn
patrice o'neill rich voss uh jim norton
keith robinson like literally
this circuit bill burr i was around
comedians that were comedians but i was
so green and i wasn't getting stage time
that i would just sit back and watch all
these guys talk after a sec
i would just watch them all sit in the
room you would listen into what they
were saying listen
and just be a sponge but they didn't
consider you one of the groups no they
were ahead of you yes
way ahead of me you know some people sit
at the other table who were the guys who
mentored you back then
who finally left robinson keith robinson
man keith robinson
uh that's your guy keith robin is not
only my guy that's my
brother my what did he do for you he did
everything
keith robinson was the guy that gave me
information keith robinson was the guy
that said
the material that you have is stupid
that you're not talking about anything
keith robinson is the guy that said
do you want to be a comedian that's
for one group of people or do you want
to appeal to everybody
right you want to be interesting or do
you just want to be cool and quick funny
do you want to tell a story do you want
people to know about you your life
he opened up the floodgates as to what
material was and what it should be
right he made me understand why coming
to new york
was better than going anywhere else
because of the plethora of people
it's a pot of exposure to the the top
people everybody is here when you talk
about ethnicities you
you have some of everything here that's
how you get big that's how you become
universal in other words you have to
appeal to all audiences
you can't just be a black audience you
can't you've got to appeal to every
person that you can get under that tent
he showed me how to put work into the
craft of comedy
i i suspect uh based on what i've read
is that
colin quinn too was a good guy was a
great guy i like colin a lot colin quinn
was a great guy until this day i still
have a good relationship with colin but
what's
what's best about colin quinn was he was
one of the first people
of stature that embraced me and and made
me feel like
a friend you know and because he
introduced you to jerry seinfeld
and tracy morgan and chris rocky come
here come here
meet this guy this nice little kid over
here he's funny little stupid kid but
he's funny
like i was watching chappelle's special
and chappelle gave you like the ultimate
compliment i think
i think chris rock did too they were
like my kids don't think i'm cool
they want to they want to meet kevin
hart they think he's funny
is that when you're sitting and watching
that kind of stuff going on do you pinch
yourself and say man i can i mean i get
the chills just saying that
i mean these two great comics are saying
it's the best compliment that that you
can be given but
you know i'm i'm also a student of the
game so
regardless of where i am in my career
now regardless of
my accomplishments i'm able to do the
things that i'm doing because of the
doors that they open
but do you ever sit there when you watch
uh i don't know let's say you watch
seinfeld or one of these guys
do you say to yourself [ __ ] i wish i had
written that joke i wish i had
all the time you get jealous all the
time you should and i think that
that's a that's a compliment to the
writing that they have i mean dave
chappelle i can give you a story about
dave chappelle me chris rock i told
chris rock i was going to the comedy
cellar here in new york
he said i'ma come down i said chris you
i'm working on some stuff come down
i want to know what you think we're
we're close and we know we always give
each other opinions on what we're doing
and
where we feel this can go or that can go
just punch up so he comes down
he's like oh my god kev funny i said you
going up he's like yeah i'm gonna try
some stuff out too chris goes up
dave pops in later that night me and
chris were there talking chappelle comes
in
we say you going up he said yeah me and
chris go downstairs
so we can watch dave keep in mind me and
chris are excited we just worked on new
material right chris gave me some good
beats
he went on i gave him some good beats
dave went on stage
and was so good right that me and chris
just took what we had we balled it up
we threw it away we threw it i said
i said i i'm so disgusted with where my
level of thinking was
after seeing where dave was i gotta go
back in the gym
you